well a house fire in the west valley
leads police to uncover something
illegal happening inside hundreds of
marijuana plants were growing in that
home happened on sunday in a
neighborhood near buffalo and flamingo
madison kimbrough heard from neighbors
who say they were just shocked by this
discovery
according to people in this neighborhood
they had no idea what was going on
inside of this home but on sunday one
neighbor recalls seeing sparks coming
out of this electrical meter and
immediately called police i came outside
and i saw
sparks and flames at the bottom of the
electrical box and i saw smoke going up
neighbors recall what they saw sunday
morning as this residential home caught
fire in the spring valley neighborhood
when police and fire crews arrived it's
what they found inside the home that
really had residents talking when you
hear something like a fire happening in
a house that's growing
pots you just go crazy
like this isn't supposed to happen in my
neighborhood according to metro police
there were 812 marijuana plants weighing
more than 300 pounds found inside the
house with rigged electrical work
modified gas lines lighting and
fertilizer all in place neighbor zachary
salzman says he's surprised something
like this would take place here because
he hardly sees anyone around the
property maybe we saw one person come
every every so often but
it was really quiet we thought no one
really lived here luckily the fire did
not spread to any surrounding homes and
was contained fairly quickly sunday
morning no injuries were reported and
narcotics detectives are currently
following up on leads at this time and
we reached out to metro to get stats on
illegal grow houses across the valley
we're waiting to hear back reporting
from flamingo in buffalo madison
kimbrough live local now